you not doing stuff with AI is just like
the thing you made fun of your parents
for not doing with the internet this is
the Internet 1992. it's that big it's
not going away and it will make your
life so much better when you're in the
kitchen saying hey Alexa can you order
me food for two friends one's lactose
intolerant order now boom and that saves
you 18 minutes of going to the website
or calling or being on your Seamless app
or ubereats this is going to make your
life better like everything of course
there'll be some things that aren't good
but there aren't some things that are
good about everything alcohol has some
bad things a car like everything has bad
and good please don't do the AI what
you've done to everything else it's
going to be a part of our Lives rather
it's going to affect everything when I
say everything everything so the quicker
you get used to it the better your life
will be